we're going to turn it over now to two
very talented people that you may
recognize from the world of ice dancing
that's Maya and Alex shubatani they are
better known as the ship sibs I love
that their Artistry and athleticism has
won fans
won over many many fans in this look at
these guys on this gold medal winning
performance at the U.S Nationals in
2016. the siblings have two Olympic
bronze medals three World medals and
eight U.S national medals including two
national championships you go super ties
they're also new members of the U.S
figure Skating Hall of Fame now they're
out look at this with a new children's
book it's called amazing Asian Americans
in Pacific Islanders who Inspire us all
it features 36 Trailblazers and everyone
from well-known figures like the Grammy
winning we know rock grammy-winning
artist her and vice president Kamala
Harris to lesser-known people like White
House Executive Chef that's Chris Chris
Comerford I remember her astronaut
kalpana
chawla who have helped Shaped America
Maya and Alex shubatani we're very glad
to say are joining us in the studio
bravo bravo guys it's really really good
to have you here and can I just say Well
done well done I learned a lot reading a
book so I have to thank you for that but
I love guys how you said listen
everybody open your imaginations these
people persevered for themselves and for
others and you say it's very important
to say Asian Americans and Pacific
Islanders why Alex the goal of this book
is to uplift both communities because
it's not all definitely
definitely such a vast and diverse
community group of communities and so we
want to create this book and we're so
excited for people to read it because we
think it'll be an amazing thing for the
Next Generation yeah how did you narrow
it down to 36 oh yeah it was that's what
I thought it was challenging and how did
did you get into one paragraph that's
the other thing it's so well done 36 is
certainly not the BL end-all hopefully
this will just be a wonderful
introduction for people to the Asian
American and Pacific Islander
communities and with the paragraph We
want to share more about each figure
than just one sentence and so that
combined with the beautiful
illustrations will be great for readers
of all ages yeah Alex go ahead there's
one case in particular I want to talk
about the 14th Amendment says anyone
born on American soil is an American
citizen but that had not been challenged
until there was a case in the 1800s an
Asian American trying to return from
China he'd been born here yes it was
stopped and went all the way to the
Supreme Court tell us what happened in
that case Wong kemark he is the first
figure featured in our book amazing his
story is incredibly impactful like you
mentioned he was born in San Francisco
and Upon returning to the United States
after a trip to China was barred from
entering and he fought for his rights
and that is why any child born in the
United States now has Birthright
citizenship it's an amazing amazing tale
did you feel one of the things that's
always difficult is and why authors like
you are so important is because you
don't see books like this when you were
children growing up you didn't find
you're self-represented in either film
or television or in literature talk to
me about what it's like now to have
young children who are going to have
access to these stories the one that
Tony just pointed out which I promise
you most people do not know did not know
Tony that was the example I was going to
give too yeah that exact example I
didn't know I didn't know that it's
going to be incredible for the Next
Generation to go into a bookstore see a
cover like this with all those different
faces on it right next to the word
amazing and for that to be their normal
because you're right we didn't grow up
with a book like this and there are real
world implications when it comes to a
lack of visibility and representation in
education in media and so we hope that
this book can kind of contribute to
furthering the cause and taking us
forward but Alex when you were growing
up did you both think there are no books
that look like me I used to think that
about dolls I never thought that did you
did you actually have that thought when
you were a little kid I think that when
you're reading a book you can empathize
with a character even if you don't see
yourself and so what we hope with this
book is that yes it is for the next
generation of Asian Americans and
Pacific Islanders but we want it to
reach the hands of kids everywhere
because that empathy that understanding
and then eventually hopefully respect
will follow them through the rest of
their lives and how they treat others
yeah I've heard you say it's a
children's book but it has worldwide
implications what do you mean yeah I
mean I think that you know when we were
thinking about this project and wanting
to create this book it was the middle of
the pandemic or I guess like the the
early stages of the pandemic and the
Asian American and Pacific Islander
communities were experiencing a serious
uptick in violence and hate crimes and
we wanted to do something to to help and
in addressing kind of the core issue we
do believe that education and that
understanding is so important especially
at a young age and unfortunately aapi
history is not required curriculum
Nationwide and so while this book is I
think it's should be because you know
it's American history that's right and
and so we feel strongly about that and
we hope that this book is something that
can maybe get families engaged and have
these conversations before kids get to
school yeah because
um my Alex is something that's really
important I think which is that yes you
know you want uh members of the Asian
American Community Pacific honors to
read this book
um and perhaps see themselves
represented but there's a whole world
out there of people who don't know these
stories who are not members of the aapi
community and you want them to read this
too shouldn't just be for kids who are
Asian Americans or Pacific Islanders
definitely yes and that's why it's
important for us to have historic and
contemporary figures as well you always
get along this well number one I love
watching on the eyes together I saw you
in the Green Room you clearly look at
each other you're very engaged with each
other and you get on each other's nerves
do you ever argue do you what is the
deal with Alex is a great older brother
we're a great team I saw the the earlier
segment by the way not as much family
feuding yeah
we're a great team we've always gotten
along really well since we were kids and
I think that that's been so valuable and
sort of us being able to aim high and
try to accomplish our goals whether it
be on the ice or now with this book it's
amazing watching you guys trade off no
no I like it no stepping on each other I
think the two of you are amazing thank
you so much Bravo Bravo this is very
well done and it's beautiful too love
the illustration thanks for being here
Maya and Alex shubatani the book is
called amazing it's on sale now wherever
you like to buy your books